ich hab das ich spüre das wirklich immer
wenn ich hierhin noch verdecken wir es
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer ich
schaffe das jetzt schon wieder oder was
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen projekt und zwar zu der
adventure web moment ich summe an der
challenger version 1.0 wir haben hier
die regeln und ich mache das nicht
alleine sondern mit konkret p hallo das
ist martin mit martin habe ich mal auf
meinem zweiter count konz block sein
auto video gemacht wonach ups das thema
leid ich wollte gleich lang gips wird
zweimal geschlagen lass es sein alter
wollen wir nicht vertreiben okay einige
fragen sich jetzt mit dem was konkret
luca das war doch damals den altar
account und martin hat keinen richtigen
weg und deswegen habe ich in dem bekommt
gesponsort ja sehr nett vor die muss ich
sagen ich weiß okay weil er liegt nur
ganz kurz die regel davor ich also ein
bis zwei spieler keine blöcke zerstören
keiner jeezy monsters of und spaß haben
ach du scheiße ich aufhören kaka nicht
rechts erwartet muss kurz 20.000
schlafengehen so was sie noch sagen
wollte ist dass wir ab und zu den
bildschirm wechseln ich hatte keine lust
also martin sitzt grad neben mir
wahrscheinlich hört ihr uns manchmal
gegenseitig und werden dass ihr grad
alles technisch sehr professionell
ich sitze am tisch und er sitzt der 5er
hat das geht von 30 auf das rohde und ja
wir werden das ab und zu wechseln das
heißt es kann sein dass sie in 23
minuten hier martins bildschirm seht
also martinsspiel eingeblendet und dann
spielt er halt und damit wir das alles
ein bisschen abwechseln haben wir sind
change inzwischen durch dafür steckt ja
das ist ja darf ich den schalter drücken
was passiert ist aufgegangen
ja ich hab doch mit minecraft ohne ihn
wieder irgendwie zu minecraft
hohenwestedt so gut das war game 03 10
18 f sand des todes machen
wir müssen fragen was wtf was hast du
gemacht so dass ich so laut schreit
macht dich das adventliche doppelte was
egal oder klar war aus wtf ich glaube du
hast etwas falsch gemacht nein warum
achter kann hinterher ja was kommt jetzt
raus gar nix kommt als irgendwas und ich
habe angst dass ihr wieder in die lava
kommt ich habe angst machen irgendwie
monster.com ist offen
es ist schon offen ok cool ich habe auf
jeden fall schon mal ein knochen
also wir haben uns jetzt vorher schon
alles mögliche geholt ich hab den
schalter j wir haben uns vorher schon
ganz viele chicken wings von casey
geholt als ich klein war wollte ich
eigentlich dicht machen scheinen
geworden so hin
ich bin hier raus opfer moment ich hab
doch heraus siehst du ja auch
esskastanien minecraft okay weiter
geht's das erschwert ich habe schon drei
von diesen teilen weg vor hätten ja weiß
ich doch nicht das game 2 cloud desktop
also wie schon gesagt dass du die
scheiße martin los wie sie wissen ich
runtergefallen als das tut mir leid dass
ich wirklich kein minecraft zaun hat
aber ich werde da hilft ist ich werde
einfach mal hinterlegen so schlecht wenn
ein fach musik hinterlegen und dann wird
das glaube ich schon passen nicht in der
folge geschafft dass du zurück
schalte ich bin falsch gesprungen nein
also hier seht ihr mal die neb die ist
echt ziemlich groß es kann echt
eventuell sein das wasser durch
verwechseln wechseln die an sich kann
auch sein dass er jetzt gerade schon bei
martin seit ich weiß gar nicht ok oder
vielleicht könnt ihr mir auch in die
kommentare schreiben andere sachen die
ihr denkt wie wir das eventuell besser
machen können damit ihr beides steht
oder so oder nicht mit wechsel keine
ahnung
martin hat mir schon gesagt dass man das
eigentlich ganz gut hinkriegt was mit
dem wechseln bild wechseln und so du
bist ja ich bin hier nur damit du es mir
gesagt dass das andere so machen und das
klappt da alter auf wie bescheuert ich
war ganz am ende schon bei mir sprint
hätte er nicht bei dir nicht geschlagen
doch jetzt geht es schon laptop
du arschloch verstand dieses game das
ist das game 28 wie schon beim 2 1
es ist eigentlich gar nicht so schwer
jetzt schreiben alle in die kommentare
dass wir so übel scheiße sind
wer nichts gut 32 ist schon links tod
gedacht ich hasse jump'n'run so ich
hoffe dass jetzt das habe ich in green
jacket und er fällt auch unseren kanal
21 und martin ist genau jetzt tot
andere machen
anfang januar ist unsere richtung ist
weg scheiße auch schon bemerkt schon
verpackt
wenn martin meinker du bist so ein
lappen frau ich schaffe das jetzt aber
ich habe das ich spüre das wirklich
immer wenn ich hierhin auferlegt mir so
wie es eigentlich gar nicht so schwer
ich hab das jetzt schon wieder oder was
also richtig blöder fehler einfach
weitergelaufen und nicht gesprungen war
nach ruhig du schaffst das
ich warte jetzt auch nach jedem sprung
doch nicht das langweilig muss ich hin
und wieder zurückfuhr
hab ich mich erschrocken ich schaff das
gerade das krise schwer sein an
scheinbar schon beim ersten sprung
agrokraft ages vor der luke und so
murray
ey du schwebst wenn wir aber im boden
geschieht ist freiheit jetzt achte ich
mach das jetzt alles in einem neuen hast
du wenig man ey ich habe mich bei den
hessen sprung nach mich fragt so weiter
und dann musst du dich mit was du in mir
drin da war ja auch schon links nicht
war schon kurz vorm ziel
hdf scheiße man halt die fresse warte
warte ist kommt wegen der warte kuba wo
ich bin ich mal ein bisschen ich habe
schon alle kissen gehen können
warum bin ich eigentlich nicht achtet zu
blöd an du bist so genannten ja sagt
martin
das wissen martin ist drei meter groß
und wiegt zehn kilo zinke 49
nein sprinter doch mal okay ich bin
schon wieder da wo ich vorher war
schaffe ich von hier nicht einfach so
die kiste zu öffnen ihnen wie eigentlich
muss nur den schalter machen
ich hab's ich habs jetzt muss ich wieder
zurück springen und maniche hatte 66
die atrexx auf ich bin so ein tier die
muschel zu schaffen game 3 1 2 oder 3 1
meinhardt
ok ich würde sagen jeder von uns eins
ich nehme erst mal ich nehme 31 ist
richtig direkt richtig entschieden
ja du bist jetzt mal gegen die wand
gefahren oder so was wussten dabei der
was kamen dann bei dir ich bin weiter
gefahren hat ach da muss man sich
reinsetzen le matin die sind dazu da
dass bei mir schwebt noch auf kiste rum
ich hab dich wieder zurück und nochmals
nein
ok jetzt kommt meine hand das voll
komisch meine hand ist richtig behindert
gerade für minecraft in mein kalt so ich
würde sagen wieder 1
ich mache jetzt zwei okay 1 ist falsch
ich bin gestorben opfer
zwar ist richtig toll fußball gott hat
mir von ihr machen back to start was ist
das hier warte ich komme dann können wir
gucken
ich bin gleich da
komme es jetzt an nackten text wir haben
es schon gemacht du holst du hast dingen
ziehe ich mich zurück
die lappen er kommt auch nicht zurück du
musst dich auch daran setzen
martin links blick nicht welches blick
recht wenig links blick dort gab es
jetzt kommt ist extra sohn dingsbums da
musste ich einfach dein weinkarten
packen reinsetzen kriegs auf knopf und
fest zurück zum start
ich bin hinter dir
falls ich verwirrt du bist hinter mir
ich komme nicht weg warte ich gehen aus
mike card und dann acht danke hier und
jetzt in 40
ich finde hier siehst mich nicht es kann
durch mich durchgelaufen
bei mir war es so gerade weg muss ich
jetzt hier hoch schwimmen oder was hast
du mich jetzt ja ich hab dich okay gut
siehst mich jetzt immer noch mal noch
martin setz mich immer noch hallo siehst
mich noch martin belassen bis gleich tot
martin skype ist glaub ich dann abgehakt
ja okay ich werde martin noch aber ihr
halt mal die wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
weiß charta plakat ist moment war ich da
mal kurz den anderen geber kurzem skype
und nimm das an
was hast du in tampa weg nach deswegen
hass auf das spiel verlassen
technische probleme hier ja deinen
scheiß internet aber screen floss bei
dir noch andere ja okay ich hab nur noch
anderthalb cent auf da hat noch wirklich
nur anderthalb herauf kennt ihr lover
ist apple da würde ich schon wieder ein
schreibfehler vor gott der gamma vier
geschrieben bekommen wir gehen legen uns
erschlaffen quartett wenn wir es nur
verlosen sell out of the world welt
aufgefordert ja toll wir müssen jetzt
hier durch das sind so schwer
was daran so schwer hier ist doch pastor
martin hofer chance
du bist schlecht achterschiff kurz vor
mir getötet nicht mehr gegen la war ja
komm mach nix arschloch verläuft stabil
wie die geschichte vom schickst du mich
auch provoziert richtung a
jetzt komm ich mache nichts mehr
das geht weiter
hier sind wieder mein card so wir müssen
wieder weiterfahren und hier sind auch
mein okay kommt erwarte ich es wasser da
müssen wir darauf setzen dass man kann
hier drin jetzt mich hier raus gefallen
drin popstar kurz an
dank solchen boot von lowe's plus ding